vision dimanche une marche contre le
travail des enfants arrivera en france
avec un reportage en inde l'humanité
d'odenas scandale 250 millions d'enfants
exploités dans le monde
il ya eu un peu d'écho sur des scandales
on sait maintenant par exemple ça a été
dit à plusieurs reprises que les
millions de ballots de foot qui se
vendent dans le monde sont fabriqués par
des enfants
donc il commence à y avoir une
sensibilisation mais justement c'était
pour nous l'occasion en publiant ce
reportage
à l'occasion l'entrée de la marche en
france c'était l'occasion de l'essayer
de donner un retentissement important et
d'appeler nos lecteurs à se joindre aux
initiatives qui accompagneront le
passage de la marche en france là